[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
display you're watching this on is flat
it's flat your tvs are flat your
computer monitor is flat your phones and
your tablets are flat and that's fine
that's what everyone is basically used
to by now but a new interesting form
factor has kind of arrived in just this
year 2013 and that's curved displays but
what is a curved display and why would
anyone want that on their phone what is
the point well taking us back to the
beginning of this year in january 2013
that's where we first saw this
technology in samsung's
the first samsung yam devices featured
partially curved oled displays one with
an angled portion to the side and
another one with an angled portion to
the bottom and the goal of these devices
was to use that software to only light
up the curved portion of the display for
notifications and glanceable information
but these were prototypes so they never
really saw mass production or were sold
anywhere but flash forward to now
october of this year and we're seeing
the first devices where the entire
display is curved namely the samsung
galaxy round the galaxy round has a 5.7
inch 1080p oled display has a snapdragon
800 processor three gigabytes of ram
it's running android 4.3 it's basically
the same exact specs as the galaxy note
3 but instead of having a 3200 milliamp
hour battery it has a 2 800 milliamp
hour battery because it's curved yeah
this phone's entire display is curved
from side to side about that center axis
why you may ask well right now again
it's another one of samsung's little
thought experiments to see how people
react to this but they've actually
included some interesting software
enhancements that actually take
advantage of this phone's unique shape
it uses the accelerometer and the
gyroscope to sense when the phone is
tilting and when it does tilt it
provides glanceable information and
notifications when you rock it on a
table plus there are other motion
controls for the gallery and the music
and other apps that i'll take advantage
of you being able to rock this phone on
a table basically there's a whole ton of
crazy samsung stuff that will be able to
do all this awesome stuff when it knows
that the phone is tilted but not
everyone has their phone on a table all
the time to tilt we have it in our
pockets and in our hands and even up to
our faces to make calls so lg thought of
that and almost immediately after
samsung revealed the galaxy round some
leaks got out of a curved display phone
that lg is working on the lg g flex this
phone is curved from top to bottom about
the center axis and a bit more
dramatically too it has a 700 millimeter
curve radius which is about twice as
much as a samsung galaxy nexus curve
here's a mock-up to scale of what that
curve looks like from top to bottom so
you can see it's definitely not a shy
curve but there's a good reason we
haven't seen phones with curves this
much until this year so there's a
difference between curved glass
and curved display that displaces
beneath the glass and phones like the
galaxy nexus and other curved phones
like that had curved glass so the glass
on top of the display was curved up a
bit but the display panel underneath it
was still flat and once you get the
curve of the glass too much off above
the display you'll start to get some
distortion issues and a little bit of
touch responsiveness and accuracy issues
but when you curve the display right up
underneath the glass you start to open
up a whole new world of possible shapes
and curves for the slab form factor
touch screen and trust me it gets really
really crazy but going back to the
question why would you want it why would
you want a curved display smartphone
that's going to be up to you and that's
up to manufacturers to convince you that
you want it by value ads and adding
software and things like that and
features that you can have on a curved
display smartphone that you can't have
on a non-curved display smartphone and
they'll be trying to use these things to
convince you you want it and see how it
goes
because there are definitely
disadvantages right now at this point to
also having a curved display smartphone
number one is obviously battery life you
can curve the display as much as you
want but the batteries got to go
somewhere and battery cells don't curve
you can only really stack them on top of
each other so you'll either get a really
thick phone or a really small battery
and then there are other minor things
like the video viewing experience which
could look a little bit weird watching a
full screen video on a curved display a
little bit of distortion and other
things like you know the typing on a
table while it's rocking back and forth
experience could be weird and ultimately
the durability issue because you know
it's not like it was a good idea to put
your phone in your back pocket and sit
down anyway but now you could literally
damage your phone by sitting down the
wrong way now notice i haven't said the
word flexible
once curved displays and flexible
displays are different things curved
displays and curved smartphones already
actually being manufactured flexible
smartphones are still a long way off
we've seen a ton of amazing flexible
displays this year too especially again
at the beginning of this year at ces
samsung showed off a ton of awesome
stuff with flexible displays but
ultimately in a phone you can make that
display as flexible and wobbly as you
want but the rest of the phone is still
rigid the battery is still rigid the cpu
and the ram and all the components
underneath it are still rigid that's why
anytime you see a portable smartphone
display you always see a whole bunch of
components hanging off of it that would
be the rest of the smartphone ultimately
though this is all just experimentation
at this point but you know what else
started off as experimentation the
galaxy note line and look where that is
now that did quite well so that's
exactly what this is and samsung's not
afraid to take chances at this point
because you could have a runaway success
like that so that's exactly what the
galaxy round is an experiment and who
knows maybe it'll take off the exact
same way the galaxy note line did we're
voting with our wallets on this one and
if we the people buy it then companies
will absolutely work much harder on this
and start to develop and mature the
technology but right now it's definitely
still in its infancy and when a
technology is still in its infancy it's
still pretty expensive hence the galaxy
round is retailing for around a thousand
dollars off contract right now in korea
but again when this develops and when
this starts getting much more mature
we're going to see some pretty awesome
things in the next generation of
smartphones so what do you think curve
display smartphones galaxy round lg g
flex is any of this stuff interesting to
you guys i think i'll wait for the
galaxy round two in a couple years
either way thanks for watching this
video guys hope you enjoyed and if you
did definitely leave a thumbs up below
but more importantly there's a subscribe
button below if you want to see more
videos like this on a regular basis
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
you